so your first three feature films have
grossed 800 million I haven't checked
that sounds about right yeah sure okay
why not
is this something ten years ago you
would have ever you you and Lata would
have ever imagined I mean not to sound
like a jerk but in a way yes well cuz I
mean it was only always my dream to make
movies and it was always my dream to be
a Hollywood director but that was kind
of like a secret because I'm you know
I'm from Sweden and it's like the other
side of the world like I don't have any
like family members or in showbiz or
anything like that so I might like you
can say to friends and family like yeah
I'm gonna be a whole word director
because people are gonna be like yeah
sure like I'm gonna be the king of Spain
whatever you know but that was always
the goal and then it's been you know a
lot of times that goal has felt really
far away and I've been very depressed
and it felt like well this is never
gonna happen of course but that was
always the goal like that was what I
wanted to do with my life so in a way
it's been you know you can't say that
it's been expected but it's always been
the goals it's always been like yeah
that's what I really want so so it's
more of like you know the feeling is not
that surprised
well it is a feeling of surprise that
wow it actually happened what I want
you know my dream actually came true but
the dream has always been there if that
makes sense and when you were in Sweden
you were posting short films and like
animated films to your YouTube channel
yeah and were you working another job or
you were in an animation um I actually
haven't had a lot of jobs I so my I
think video store was my first job which
was sort of under the table not really
official but but it was it was kinda
cool I I loved it because yeah I had
access to movies I could rent all these
free movies and sometimes you get
screeners so you could see movies before
they came out on video and things like
that but I've never been
much of a people person what so I mean
it's a you know you have to talk to
people a lot which is that was the
downside of it about all the movies that
was a great part and then I worked a
little bit in like grocery stores and
things like that and I hated that even
more because that's you know the
downsides of working in a video store
but without the movies so and then I was
unemployed for quite a while it's really
depressed there was you know still
living with my mom in my 20s and
eventually yeah I started making
animation because I've always wanted to
make movies I was making movies with
friends but then as we started getting
older you know your friends are getting
jobs and lives and suddenly it's like
I've there's not as much time to and
willingness to make little dumb shorts
so that's when I started doing animation
because it was something I could do all
by myself
I didn't have to rely on other people's
schedules or money or whatever it was
just like I've always liked drawing so I
could do that on my computer all by
myself I'll just record the voices and
didn't even need an expensive camera for
it and I was lucky in that this was in
2005 2006 when YouTube was a new thing
so you know I signed up to that didn't
really know what it was but it's like
okay I can upload videos here and I
uploaded a little animated short I made
and got a really good response like
people really seem to like it so was i
well this is great so I made another one
one that was a little bit more ambitious
than the first one the first one was
almost like a slide show I mean I
hesitate to call it animation because it
was it's an actual slide show but then
the second one I got more ambitious with
and I made this story that was very
personal about sort of the thoughts in
your head that put you down and like
tell you that you're and you know
basically an angel and the devil on your
shoulder and that one really took off on
line got all these views and then really
went viral but it was in Swedish so it
didn't go outside of Scandinavia but
like Norway
Denmark and people it's Finland and that
got me a lot of attention I got like to
go on TV and like what's it like to have
a viral hit and it also led me led to me
getting some jobs like companies or like
we want to make a little funny video
about our product or whatever and we
loved your funny video can you do
something for us
and I would do that and often it's kind
of funny because the the shorts I made
were very crude I think they have a lot
of bad language and like being penis and
and things like that and of course when
companies want to do something is like
yeah we want that but not that you know
so you kind of have to do yeah it's
something that's not as fun but now I
was actually getting some money getting
paid which was great and so I could move
out and didn't have to live with my mom
anymore and this also led to me meeting
my wife I mean that we actually dated
when we were 11
oh she was into acting I was already
into making movies and then when this
short went viral she saw it and you know
yeah we dated when we were 11 then had a
14-year break and she saw this movie and
was like recognized my voice and
contacted me to reconnect and we did and
got back together and now you know when
we now were dating you know she was an
actress you know I had a video camera
it's like oh we can make things together
and we tried getting money from the
Swedish Film Institute because in Sweden
you know you applied for grants from the
film institute for your short or even
for your features that's basically how
all movies are made there but we didn't
have any look because they weren't us
interested in sort of the John Ross
stuff that we wanted to do and I think
I've always had sort of four always had
sort of a commercial bent for movies
like that's kind of my taste you know
American fun popcorn movies and things
like that and in Sweden especially when
you have a grant based system and it's
taxpayer money and they have to be
really responsible what they do with
that money it often goes to films that
are more sort of important and take up
sort of issues with society and things
like
that nothing wrong with AI mean it's led
to some great movies but yeah it didn't
really work out for us so we were turned
down and then we felt like well screw it
I mean you're an actress I have a camera
we let's just do something you know we
don't need money we can do a little
shorts ourselves so we did a little
short call came closer that was a horror
short but like a thumb that sees the
future I put that up on my youtube
channel that now had a few thousand
followers from my animated work and they
were kind of surprised a lot of the
followers because they expected sort of
humorous animated things in the house
unleash this terrifying little horror
short but people still seem to like it
even though they were surprised and we
really enjoyed doing it and then we saw
this there was an online contest by
these horror collective in the UK called
bloody cuts like make a under
three-minute hard film and you can win
prizes and things so we were like well
that's what we're doing now we just did
camp closer let's do something for this
and that's when we did lights out again
just me and Lata in our apartment trying
to like figure out okay what can we do
that's scary and we're like you know I
think everyone's I had that feeling of
you know in our house it was a coat rack
that you walk out in the middle of the
night like ooh looks like someone
standing there and you turn on the light
so there's nothing there and that's sort
of how it you know playing around with
the light give us this idea of okay
there's there's something that actually
is there every time you turn off the
lights so we did that uploaded it to the
contest and then we found out that we
didn't win the contest but then a little
while later they also had secondary
prizes so I won Best Director looks like
oh that's awesome
but we didn't think that anything else
would happen with that we were like oh
you know fun let's make more movies but
then a few months after that this was in
March 2014
I saw him ready that someone had linked
to our short and
it's like oh that's awesome I show Lotte
and then I go in to see the stats and it
was like 17,000 years since I called
it's so much that's awesome and then
just minutes later it was like 70,000
views and then it was up over 140,000
views and it just kept going and going
it's like what's happening but I think I
mean it was just two and a half minutes
short and there's no dialogue in it I
think that really helped it to spread I
mean partly because you know people
don't have an attention span anymore so
it's like if they see you know it's the
only two and a half minutes I can watch
that and because there's no dialogue it
can spread everywhere so we've really
sort of lucked into something that was
really Universal and yeah it was just a
few days after that I actually said to
look that you know I've heard of people
getting representation in Hollywood from
Shores like for managers and agents and
things like that and like the day after
I said that I woke up to an email from a
management firm here in hall when I
showed love those like I told you it's
like it's starting and then it was just
like open the floodgates because we got
emails from agents and managers and
producers and studios and like sometimes
actors and then people live as well a
makeup artist and all these things like
what is this and you know these managers
and agents that want to represent us and
you know I had to get like an IMDB Pro
account just to find out who these
people are and eventually I you know I
picked a manager who could then help us
navigate this whole thing we're getting
an agent and then who can we trust with
producers and all of that and yeah we've
this producer the Lawrence Gray seemed
really good and he was really into it
you know because a lot of them were just
wanted to know who we were and what our
plans were you know and you don't know
like they didn't explicitly say we want
to make this movie or we want to
represent you so and I kind of need that
because I'm Swedish and kind of
introverted like I'm not good with sort
of
interpreting subtle signs like so so I
went with like the producers like yes I
want to make this movie we should make
this movie boom the cycle alright let's
go we went with with Laurence Gray who
and you know it was kind of a weird
situation because once this happened it
was about a year before the movie
happened which is actually pretty quick
but it feels strange in that situation
to sort of wait for all of these things
and not knowing if it's real if it's
actually gonna happen or not because
during this year it was you know signing
with a management firm and an agency and
all that and then finding a writer
working with the writer to develop a
script and making a deal for all this
with you know getting a lawyer and all
of that so during this year left and I
we didn't know if this was actually real
or if it was all
so we were like well we can't stop going
so we kept making shorts um you know
around our house where we could come up
with little new ideas we made one in the
attic one in the basement and just try
and come up with new stuff and you know
for each of these shorts I would make
these a little behind the scenes videos
that was that turned out to be very
appreciated by people who who saw this
like other up-and-coming filmmakers and
it was something I did just because I
loved that's what I wanted to see I
wanted to see you know I've always loved
seeing behind the scenes and making of
xand all these because you know just to
learn as much as possible and see what
it's like on a film set and how do you
create these things and all that so we
just kept doing that and we even had
this idea that we would make a feature
just her and I this didn't pan out but
then in March something like that of
2015 they basically saw yeah movies is
happening we need you here like next
week or whatever so look uh basically
had to quit her job because you were
working in a group home you know I was a
freelance animator so I didn't have
anything steady going
so we basically you know locked our
apartment got on a plane and this was
you paid for about the studio because we
were broke
like when we first got a manager you
know they were like can you get out here
because we want you to meet all these
people and go like on this you know tour
of Hollywood's like oh hey this is this
guy and whatever but we didn't have any
money so it's like yeah we can't do that
but then they pay for us to have to fly
out here and yeah it was very strange we
we had to find a place to live here and
it's everything is super expensive in LA
but we found on it and Airbnb this half
a garage in Burbank it was sort of part
of Institutes of this mother and her
daughter were our neighbors in this
garage it was like I mean for us it was
like two-and-a-half grand or something
my mother
Russ that is insane yeah I I mean it was
a pretty nice garage I mean wasn't bad
or anything but it was quite a shock to
find out how expensive it was and we
still didn't have any money and when we
got over here yeah the studio paid for
the flight over and everything and they
were gonna pay for living expenses but
not until it was greenlit and it wasn't
actually greenlit until quite late so we
had to I mean first of all we borrowed
from everyone we knew back home in
Sweden and then that money went out was
it's like knew what we do now so we had
to borrow from the producer and like a
manager and it was kind of dicey because
it was like well this doesn't happen
we're in deep because we're like
all borrowed out when it comes to money
but then thankfully it did happen the
movie but yeah it was all pretty crazy
because I had never been on a movie set
before so the first time I actually
stepped foot on a real movie set it was
asked the director it's pretty crazy I
mean especially because I mean everyone
there had more experience than me and
every assistant your PA and like they've
all done worked on real movies and I you
know and and part of me think you know I
think they kind of thought I was more
experienced than I was and you know I
wasn't gonna correct them it's like yeah
sure you wanted want me to make your
movie well but you know they would ask
me of oh do you have a DP you work with
or an editor or a storyboard artist
just know I've done all these things
myself because I've had to you know had
you and Lata previously been to Los
Angeles before this we had been yes it
was actually the year before it went
viral was the first time we were in LA
because we we had I made a little
animated documentary that it got into a
film festival in San Jose and so we got
a little bit of money from the Swedish
Film Institute to actually go to that
Film Festival and then was like well
let's go to LA as well and we have we
the the producer who we worked with to
make that whole animated documentary he
was like well let's go pitch the studios
in Hollywood and it's like what are you
insane like well what do you mean pitch
the studios have been Hollywood like how
are we gonna get in where are we gonna
do but he actually he was like no my
brother actually works at Fox in Sweden
so he can probably get us into Fox in LA
I was like okay and it was like all
right let's pitch like a horror movie or
something because I actually wrote a
little horror movie and which was my
first like script in English and
everything and we actually got to go
there and and pitch this thing but had
to sign all these disclaimers because we
weren't represented or anything and you
know it was an interesting experience
but it was clearly just like oh he's a
friend of him just you know just just
listen to it
you know I mean nothing came of it or
anything but it was still a cool
experience like yeah got to walk on the
Fox lot you know and actually sit there
and then talk movies so yeah we'd been
here before but and even got into a
studio but but that was it when you said
viral previously what year are we
talking about
and then what was what was that number
at that time you know how viral is kind
of changed like some people think a
million is no longer yeah it was in 2014
March I I mean at the time it was like
four
remember that I mean it landed on like
10 million or something or 11 million
but I mean then it's it's it's kept
going because other people have uploaded
it as well and we didn't like be like oh
we they have to take that down that's
our movie or whatever I mean it's like
they didn't change anything of simply
yeah upload with we just want people to
see it you know so I saw an upload on
Facebook
I don't trust Facebook's number though
because it was like what was that like
70 80 90 million or something I was like
I don't know what Facebook does but I
yeah sure but a lot of people seem to
have seen it yes and the one the link
that was put on reddit was at Vimeo or
YouTube that was Vimeo actually so they
then went viral on Vimeo first which
seems you know kind of unique in a way
because it seems that it's mostly
YouTube but then since it was on YouTube
as well that exploded too but it started
on on Vimeo
you